I never worked a day on this movie I
just enjoyed every minute of it the
people
[Music]
[Music]
yeah it's very exciting and it's you
know when you made the first movie we
didn't anticipate that we were going to
be allowed to make any more that wasn't
the plan and so uh you know we're we're
very humbled by the fact that we get to
create and expand this story and explore
this world a bit more
foreign
yeah no it's very inspired by the
Polynesian melanesian micronesian the
the oceanic cultures uh so a lot of the
art and the way of life either living in
the ocean uh the relationship with
nature is very inspired by our
traditional way of life and I think it's
a beautiful part of the movie that uh
there's most meaningful to me and that
that way of life has been lost by most
of humanity and that we recreate this on
Pandora to show us
um how life used to be on this planet
[Music]
all right it's very calming when you're
in the water tanks you know you're 30
feet deep there's a there's a calmness
to it you have to have you have to be
relaxed in order to get your job done um
even though it's a risky situation and
it's never been attempted what we did
before but you know at the end of the
day it's you know we get to also ride
crazy creatures inside a big pool
um you know we're grown men and that's
our job it's insane but it's uh you know
and that's a lot of fun when you get to
ride on and create how to ride a skim
Wing or how to ride a an ilu and these
crazy creatures that are designed but at
the same time we get to explore how to
bring them to life it's the kind of
experience that you'd pay to go to a fun
park to have and then that we get to do
that when we go to work it means that
for me I never worked a day on this
movie I was just like having the best
time going to have fun and uh to to play
in this world with all of this and
incredible technology I love working in
the water whether it's on top of the
water underneath the water
um anything to do with the water was
just just a gift for me and I just
enjoyed every minute
[Music]
um well we all trained to freedive all
of us including you know the movies
about a family who gets displaced Jake
and the Terry's family and it's about
protecting that family and because of
that we end up going to the atolls and
the reefs to Sikh Sanctuary which is
where Cliff's tribe is and so all of us
not only Cliff's tribe who whose
characters are born and raised on in the
water but the kids that I have we all
had to learn the technique where we
could hold our breath underwater for
many minutes at a time so we could do
scenes underwater that were action
orientated or very thrilling but also
that were very emotional and that's a
very challenging thing is to do emotion
underwater and to do it authentically
and truthfully and and also you're 30
feet deep so to not get scared and
rattled by it
[Music]
I think Jake in the first movie only
went to Pandora because his brother died
and then when he got to Pandora he was
looking for something he was looking for
some place to fit in and he found that
in a culture so far removed from
anything he could imagine and then now
he's embraced that culture and he's
created the family that he was
potentially missing from the first
um Avatar and he's built this family and
so this journey for him is one of
protecting that you know the first movie
says it open your eyes and I think Jake
opened his eyes to a different
environment a different culture and a
different way of being and to me this
movie is about protecting that
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]